one of the executives at the largest nft
marketplace in the world just got caught
insider trading nfts for personal profit
proving once again that the real way to
make money in these markets is insider
trading baby and if you don't have that
insider knowledge by the time you hear
about it you're 10 steps behind let me
walk you through this money laundering
disaster ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the 10 million dollar studio i'm your
host coffee zilla
so here's the headline right here
dodging it earlier right open c confirms
executive used insider knowledge when
buying nfts now for those of you who
don't know what insider trading is
basically where someone buys some
investment whether it be an art stock
penny stock using insider knowledge that
the public doesn't have access to yet to
gain an edge to make money from you so
what does this look like in practice let
me give you an example in 2020 there was
a secret briefing on a new exciting um
virus trying to stay monetized boys okay
this is before anyone knew about the big
one nine right and all these senators
met up and they learned about it what
did they do with this highly classified
information they bought millions of
dollars in health stock companies
because they know of course they're
about to spike in value that's what
insider trading is you take information
that the public doesn't know yet you use
it to try to make a profit in some
financial market now let me make this
clear this in theory is illegal right
it's a financial crime did those
senators go to jail no why because
no justice works okay the sec is asleep
at the wheel guys i don't know what to
tell you they've just been pounding
nyquil for years now it appears but it's
in theory illegal so with that in mind
that context let me explain what
happened with openc so the head of
product at openc is nate chastain and
last night he was accused of having
secret crypto accounts that he used to
flip nfts for a profit this twitter user
has the story hey openc why does it
appear that nate chastain has a few
secret wallets that appear to buy your
front page drops before they are listed
then sells them shortly after the front
page hype spike for profits and then
tumbles then back to his main wallet uh
with his punk on it now what he's
referring to is the fact that anytime
you go to open c they have a featured
art project and he's accusing the head
of product of using this knowledge ahead
of time to buy up
these art
art pieces and selling them for a profit
once it hit the main page and so
obviously when i saw this uh pretty big
accusation here i wanted to know did he
actually do it that sounds so obvious so
crazy what secret accounts are they so i
dived in to the blockchain this is
actually what i enjoy about crypto the
blockchain ladies and gentlemen doesn't
lie yes it's easier than ever to launder
money yes that's very true but there's
also so many people who launder it very
poorly like old nate here and so what i
love is in the past when people insider
traded it was hard to find out now
you have their their wallet addresses
it's
pretty much open and shut so the first
thing we had to do when investigating
nate to find out if he did insider trade
or not based on the uh front page of
openc we had to find which wallets
belong to him luckily for us some of
them are public like this one as you can
see it has his twitter account here but
it also has a cryptopunk so if we go
looking for this cryptopunk here we can
actually find another one of his
accounts this one right here which is
currently unnamed but look at that it's
the actual owner of this crypto punk
that's his profile picture and it has an
ethereum name nate c
dot eth nate chastain lines up
additionally it gets paid by his main
wallet which you can see here his public
wallet is paying out his nft wallet his
little secret nft wallet that he thought
no one would know about but nate didn't
just stop there as far as trying to hide
what he was doing with these um nft
insider trades see i mind mapped what he
was actually doing here which um yeah i
know i know
i know what it looks like but what this
is is a map of our boy nate's misdeeds
here he's been um laundering
money through shell accounts right uh so
it looks like this in practice this is
what one of his nft flips looks like so
nate this is nate's uh little secret nft
wallet right here which then links to
some of his other main wallets over here
uh but nate's little wallet here what he
would do is when he knew something a
drop was coming up he would send eth to
usually an intermediary wallet which
then he would uh just send all that
money to another secret wallet which
nobody has seen before ox 7942 for
example and he would do all the nft
flipping from this wallet here which is
in theory connected but sort of uh not
obviously connected to his main wallet
after the flipping was done he would
send the profits back to his main wallet
here now here's what that looks like
from the nft perspective here's that
same wallet ox 7942
and as you can see this account bought
up art pieces like spectrum of a
ramification theory for .25 ether and
quickly flipped it for 1.5 ether a
profit of about three thousand four
thousand dollars now of course we go to
the internet archive the day he was
doing this the day he was flipping this
nft guess what shows up on the front
page spectrum of a ramification theory
the exact same nft that he just flipped
for an instant profit in one day this is
how the scheme worked he then took that
extra ether he just gained and remember
he sends that back to his main wallet so
he sends five ether creates a little
shell account network and then sends
back seven ether which is like a two
ethereum profit eight thousand dollars
not bad for one day of work and just so
you know this wasn't a one time thing
here's another example he sends five
ether to this account which then sends
it over to this little shell account
where he would do his flipping so this
is
ox50d0 here it is ladies and gentlemen
also unnamed and we can see it bought up
a bunch of this
journey and her loyal fellowship
art which then it flipped from a price
of like 0.29
and he flipped it for one ether and of
course when we go back to the day that
he did this we see journey and her loyal
fellowship show up on the front page
once again showing that nate knew and
was trading what was on the front page
he's done this many many times like with
this art piece focus which of course
shows up on the front page about the
time that he bought and sold it and i
guess the big question is how much did
he make from this little uh money
laundering network or i don't know if
you call it money laundering i mean it's
very clear that he's trying to hide what
he's doing right like he there'd be no
reason if he was fine with uh being
public about this to send all this
ethereum to other addresses all these
wallets that's why i call it money
laundering because you're trying to hide
what you're doing and trying to hide
where this money is going it's very
clear he knows what he's doing is wrong
right he's not just um innocent didn't
know this was a bad thing to do like
he's very clearly trying to obfuscate
where this money's coming from and going
so the question is how much money did he
make right um it's hard to say because i
didn't go back and do every single
transaction that would take like forever
but what we do know is that his main
account where he's sending all this eve
back to has a balance of a little over
half a million dollars ladies and
gentlemen which is that all from nft
flipping i don't know i don't know right
i don't know it could be and it could be
more honestly because it could have
other shell accounts it could be less
than that um it's hard to say the point
is this is definitely insider trading
and it's definitely seriously messed up
which is why i guess today openc posted
about it and said that they learned that
one of their employees purchased items
that they knew were about to be
displayed on the front page before they
appeared there publicly and we're
flipping them it's incredibly
disappointing blah blah our
organization's not like this it's the
general like you know
company response i guess and it looks to
me they say they're gonna do their own
investigation but from what i can see
this is a pretty open and shut case when
you actually look at the associated
wallets it's clear that not only he was
doing this but it's also clear that he
was hiding it which i think is way more
egregious than if you were just doing it
out in the open the fact that you're
creating all these shell accounts means
you know what you're doing and so not to
be like uh clairvoyant or anything but i
think this guy's gonna get fired pretty
quickly as he should be frankly i mean
this is not a matter of like cancel
culture this is just uh
she's like you can't do this you're that
a product you can't trade against your
own customers it's insane what's also
interesting about this is that as people
figured out that nate did this posts
from like a month ago started to surface
where people had were starting to point
this out they noticed this art which was
featured on the front page they said
looks like nate from open c got the jump
before anyone else he put links to him
getting it and nate responds i just
wanted to secure one of these before
they all disappeared to be honest but of
course we know that's not true because
he was selling these so it wasn't
because they were going to disappear
it's because he wanted to flip them for
money so this was coming out already it
was only a matter of time and of course
we have the response in regulated
markets this would be called insider
trading and would be punishable with a
large fine and incarceration now of
course crypto being what it is not
everyone thought that any of this was a
problem here's this guy saying maybe
it's not ethical
but i'd almost definitely do the same
thing red flak
it's not like he's stealing people's
[ __ ]
he just is in a unique position to know
which products are almost definitely
going to pump before they do that's
insider trading
let's be real it'd be kind of dumb not
to take advantage now this guy responds
it's called insider trading and it's
illegal at least in the fiat world now
this whole exchange is hilarious to me
um especially this guy people who kind
of defend it and go ah it's not that bad
it's just funny to me crypto crypto
people like this who think that like
illegal things in fiat are perfectly
okay
in the crypto world why it's funny to me
is that these are the same types of
people that are gonna get on wall street
bets and cry about the injustice of the
insider trading that goes on on wall
street they see that as a problem right
nobody defends the wall street guys
inside of trading everyone kind of
understands that that's obviously wrong
that people with insider uh knowledge
are basically betting against you and
you lose out because of that crypto
seems to like break people's brains
where they think like things aren't
illegal like ah we could just money
launder that's fine we could just uh set
up a bunch of shell accounts do some
shady stuff that's that's that's all
fine whatever look it may be fine now i
don't know uh but it's not gonna be fine
for long yes the sec is asleep right but
eventually every bear wakes up and a lot
of these guys they're gonna get taken
down but either way whether someone gets
arrested or not like this is definitely
wrong what this guy has done all this
money is extracted from their own user
base the openc user base and i think
what it shows is that um even these
so-called decentralized platforms like
openc yeah they describe themselves as
decentralized even they can be gamed by
people insider trading self-dealing
things like that because i know we were
all promised that you know we
decentralized it guys it's impossible
for anything to go wrong it's just coins
and code guys but time time and time
again that turns out to be false right
like humans do humans things some
percentage of them will always lie cheat
and steal to get ahead and i think the
point is you need some safeguards in
place to stop people from doing this and
i think you know if the average nft
person understands this the investor i
think they hopefully would think twice
about you know just jumping into a brand
new project because i think that's
that's really
a problem right now you have all these
people with insider knowledge or
influencers who can manipulate the
market and they're just doing it right
in front of you guys and if you're an
average investor that doesn't have
access to these things you're at a
disadvantage like it's a saying that
goes back forever if you're sitting at a
poker table and you don't know who the
sucker is you are the sucker the same is
kind of true with krypto specifically
these like thousand x [ __ ] coins and
stuff if you think you're getting in and
you have no idea how you're gonna make
your money um chances are people are
making money off of you
oh by the way steven from the future
here guys um just wanted to say because
it takes me forever to edit these videos
since i started making this video um
he's been fired give it up for nate
congratulations nate